brought to you by watchdogs to hack
everything available on consoles
November 15th and on PC November 29 I
don't know man I don't think she's
coming Mary it's dan how you doing if
you get this message can you call me
back we need someone to do news so yeah
give me a call back as soon as you can
Chris what is I know you know with guess
what anymore but had you want do me a
favor Justin hey mate its den if you can
give me a call back when you get this
message that would be really cool we
can't seem to get on to anyone well I
guess we're doing it first up this week
Ubisoft prove the video games are indeed
art when a player was banned for sharing
an explicit photo from watch dogs to
Twitter users Whizzer saw came across
the offending anatomically correct
character and decided to share a
screenshot Sony then issued a week-long
band for sharing content of an adult or
sexual nature Ubisoft issued a statement
to polygon stating we're aware that one
of the NPC models in watch dogs too is
rendered in a way that is particularly
explicit while watch dogs too is a
mature edit game we apologize and will
update this NPC model to make it more
consistent with other NPC models in the
game in a patch to be released this week
in a happy ending to this story suppose
I saw has seen the ban lifted by Sony
and while the patch has removed the
controversy causing texture the game is
still chock-full of ding-a-lings for
everyone to enjoy bad news for everyone
who likes role-playing is enemy
schoolchildren persona 5 has been
delayed again the certified will now
launch in the US and Europe on April for
2017 speaking during a live stream this
week the game's developers explained
that the delay is a result of the studio
needing more time to get the English
audio refined and ready I know I know it
stings set outlets that persona 5 set
the gold standard for Atlas with its
launch in Japan and we wanted to put the
utmost care into ensuring it winds up
the best when it launches in the West
the certified will eventually be
available on PlayStation 3 and 4 and
will include a dual language track
allowing for both Japanese and English
voice acting Xbox has been talking
project Scorpio this week dropping
details and output resolution and its
price point in an interview with level
up calm head of Xbox Phil Spencer
discuss Scorpios higher price point
saying Scorpio will be a premium console
it
more than s obviously that's how we are
building it further along in the
interview he reiterated that Scorpio is
not intended to replace the xbox one but
that it will live alongside the existing
systems with games and accessories
supported across both also this week
Xbox executive aaron greenberg told the
xbox fan fest in mexico city this will
really bring the most powerful console
you've ever seen it will bring these
really true 4k really incredible visual
games that we've never seen before on
the console Microsoft has already
confirmed that all of its first party
games will run at native 4k when Scorpio
releases in the 2017 holiday season take
to CEO Strauss Zelnick sits and really
vague things about red dead redemption
to this week everyone lapped it up this
copper take anything at this point
speaking at an event for the market
research firm mkm partners star said he
was quote not shocked very pleased with
the reaction to red dead tooth
announcement anticipation is enormous he
said he also spoke about how the time is
right in the world today for red dead
redemption to quote very occasionally
westerns capture the imagination of the
public when Red Dead launched it did and
those times were right for that and I
think the times are right for a big
sprawling optimistic view of America
again and that's not meant to be q
finally he's only keys that red dead 2
would offer quote incredible emotional
depth and we can expect there to be
quote great story elements and great
gameplay elements alas tres phenomenal
showers let's throw that quit in the box
and celibacy lien copies finally a
first-person shooter got an update this
week which one is it surprise it's
battlefield one what do they change
operations mode attacking side loses too
often now they have more tickets and
it's easier to capture stuff the suez
mapping conquest mode got two more flags
now a tied up for one team to lock
everything down on this tiny map now
damn in stores the size of capture
points in villages are way smaller now
and include less buildings so no more
camping the flag you sneaky bastards and
dice also add an armored car that will
help the losing side get a foot up you
can also customize your soldier from
within the UI now thank God and they
made a bunch of changes to weapon
balance LMGs now apparently more viable
as mid-range weapons and a bunch of
tweaked semantic gadgets and vehicles
also EA are running something called
battlefest for the next two weeks which
features in-game events giveaways and
you can add exclusive dog tags and
weapon skins for the full list of
details about the Pat and battlefest
check out the stories on gamespot I
implore you
now that this train wreck is basically
over you should visit gamespot com to
check out our watchdogs to coverage a
dishonor to coverage and our pokemon 26
and 27 review do it now that's all for
guinness button news this week hope you
have yourself a great weekend hopefully
by Monday they will have put us down to
be sure to come back to check up on that
hey just know I went really really well
I would be shocked if if we didn't get
the job full time honestly